thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we're glad you're
here open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five Melissa is
whether some Manchester New Hampshire hi
Melissa
how are you I'm fine thank you Dave for
taking my call sure what's up I'm hoping
you can give me a little guidance and
motivation Regis is really finished FPU
we have our emergency fund and we are as
you say killin baby step two we've been
hit with emergencies one after another
but they're they're not our emergencies
their family members notices and it's
just getting really frustrating and it's
how do we I guess I just want to know at
what point do we say no and do or do we
look at this as this is our way of
giving we have it and we don't have
emergencies so we have it too let's help
you you don't have it give $1,000 and
you're in debt right you don't have
surplus you're broke right so you have
to say no Brooke people can't help other
broke people the best way you can help
other broke people is to become unbroke
right - yeah so who's a Ewing these
family members that are always having
emergencies currently it's my dad
he's 72 years old he's a VA that he's
legally blind he's an amputee and he
just got himself in a financial mess and
just all at once and that's got too much
for him he's like okay Melissa I'm ready
for you to help me now here's my mess
fix it so I'm and that's what we're
trying to do that right now so he has an
income he has a social security income
yes was he did not have a veteran's
income retirement not currently no he
refuses to allow them to claim him 100
percent disabled because he's afraid
that that will put him in a VA home and
he does not want to go to a VA home they
don't force people into a VA
home that's what we're trying to
convince and this is this is not Russia
we don't we don't capture people and
install them into a home against their
will unless they're crazy and even then
we don't do it often enough so um yeah I
think you know he's got some other
things but the problem is he's got a
wonderful income available to him that
would probably help you solve all of
this for him but and it's due him
because he served his country right and
the some of these disabilities are due
to him his service I assume right and
the VA is trying to work with him he's
just he's just a crusty old man and he
just wants things his own way and once
things his own way but let's take your
money right
at which point it's not his own way you
want my money you do it my way
right a little role reversal at hard day
yeah I know it's hard I know it's hard
but you know you've got to explain to
him you lose your option for telling me
what to do when you asked for my help my
help involves my opinion and I'm better
at handling money than you are so dad
we're going to get your military
disability lined up here because sir you
served your country and you are due that
money and we need to get that money
coming in so we can clean up your mess
and then you're going to stop doing this
and stop doing that and stop doing this
whatever these little things are that
are using up all of his money because
he's not paying attention right and you
cannot afford to bail him out you can
afford to help him and coach him and I
think you can probably do that I'll bet
you there's enough money going around
coming in out of there or should be
coming in and out of there to clean this
up how much debt has he run up he
actually he does have enough money to
meet his monthly needs but it's just
it's been three months of him not doing
anything and just living the lap of
luxury that he hasn't paid a SAN huge so
I'm confused why you're supposed to pay
for that you're not right I and I I
agree with you but I also feel bad
I do too I feel bad for him but I'm not
gonna pay his rent hey I feel bad when a
drunk wants a drink but I'm not gonna
give him one nice that's what this is
about
yeah I do tell him that I tell you know
when when he's like I need please allow
I'll try and get him some food news that
will make sure you go when you're a
couple packs of cigarettes and an 18
pack of beer I'm like I you gotta be the
guy you've gotta be kidding me
I need some food and then he puts in his
order for beer and cigarettes yeah and
you didn't laugh yeah I do tell her no
okay so Yanni you got it you're gonna
sit down take over is you have to step
up really strongly and take care of his
finances or you're going to back off and
just let him be who he wants to be one
of the two you cannot afford to fix him
and there's always someone that's going
to have an emergency in your life as
long as they think they can push you
around but let me just tell you his
cigarettes and his beer is not your
emergency hello that now we know why is
rents not being paid so sorry but we can
honor his service we can honor his
fatherhood we do not have to honor his
misbehavior neither one of us I can
promise you I won't be that's real love
by the way it's not tough love people
those close love it's not tough love
it's just love keeping your child from
playing in the street so they don't get
hit by a car is love even if they don't
like it and they have a little fit it's
love and that's all he's doing he's
having a little four-year-old I want to
play in the street fit and so no you
can't do that anymore not gonna let you
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
bad
save room to channel I'll tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm panic so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you